comment établir le dialogue avec l'islam
de france en 2003 sous l'impulsion de
nicolas sarkozy avait été créé le
conseil français du culte musulman le
cfcm
il se voulait l'interlocuteur de l'état
français pour les questions relatives à
l'islam cette institution devait aussi
former les imams qui professe le culte
pour éviter l'émergence de discours
radicaux si l'existence d'une telle
structure par est à l'époque d'une
attention légitime 18 ans plus tard
force est de constater qu'elle est qu'un
tissu de luttes intestines son existence
a été secoué par de nombreuses crises et
elle est aujourd'hui à l'agonie il y a
un an l'avocat franco algérien chems
eddine hafiz son vice-président entre en
conflit avec l'institution et son
président franco marocain mohammed
moussaoui la raison un désaccord sur le
projet de charte des valeurs souhaité
par emmanuel macron elle devait poser
des bases comme l'interdiction de
l'instrumentalisation politique de
l'islam ou de l'ingérence d'état
étrangers elle devait réaffirmer la
compatibilité de l'islam avec la
république
mais en janvier 2021 trois fédérations
dont deux turcs refusent de signer la
charte chems eddine hafiz qui est aussi
l'actuel recteur de la grande mosquée de
paris dénonce alors l'influencent d'une
composante islamiste agissante au sein
du cfcm il quitte le bureau exécutif en
mars 2021 quatre des neuf fédérations au
sein du cfcm lui emboîte le pas
aujourd'hui le torchon n'en finit plus
de brûler on parle des problèmes posés
par l'islam dit consulaires insufflé par
les représentants de pays du maghreb ou
d'ailleurs qui tenterait d'imposer leur
vision et en novembre 2021 le conseil
français du culte musulman d'un côté et
la grande mosquée de paris de l'autre se
tape chacun de former leur propre entité
pour évaluer les imams de france mais
les trois fédérations qui refusait de
signer la charte et qui était pourtant
restée au cfcm accepte finalement de la
ratifier et par le jeu des présidences
tournantes
le dissident chems eddine hafiz devait
selon les règles en vigueur prendre la
tête du cfcm le 20 janvier pour
remplacer son rival refus des
fédérations restantes chems eddine hafiz
se détournent déclare que la fédération
de la grande mosquée de paris confirme
son retrait de toutes les instances du
cfcm les deux parties sont
irréconciliables mi-décembre gérald
darmanin le ministre de l'intérieur
donne le coup de grâce
le cfcm est mort il n'est plus
interlocuteur des pouvoirs publics
emmanuel macron a reçu les représentants
du culte le 5 janvier et ceux ci ont
organisé une assemblée générale
extraordinaire hier pour voter une auto
dissolution au profit d'une nouvelle
entité c'est la fin alors comment se
dégager des rapports de pouvoir et d
influence rigoriste ou étrangères l'état
français prend la tangente avec une
nouvelle structure en concertation avec
des responsables musulmans il élabore
une organisation plus pragmatique une
plateforme participative
le forum de l'islam de france fort ifs
il s'agit d'une centaine de musulmans
choisi dans les départements à la suite
de 300 réunions d'assises locale de
l'islam il se penche déjà sur quatre
thèmes majeurs notamment la formation
des imams et autres cadres religieux en
france dans l'esprit républicain et la
prévention des actes anti musulmans
ainsi que l'application du chapitre
droit des cultes de la nouvelle loi
confortant le respect des principes de
la république le dialogue l'entente et
la sérénité monte il enfin être au
rendez vous